[Music]
hello
and welcome to the how the light gets in
festival 2021
i'm your host for this event my name is
rana mitter and today i'll be exploring
the ark of life with a very special
guest
ayan hersey ali now ayan is a very very
well-known writer and thinker she's a
somali-born
classical liberal she's an advocate for
free speech
she's an activist for the right of women
and of girls
she's a public intellectual with a very
powerful voice
she's a former muslim who has rejected
her form of faith and become
an atheist and she's since been a vocal
critic of both islam
and the identitarian left she's written
several best-selling books including
infidel
nomad heretic and the challenge of noah
and her new book prey which i have right
here
just came out this year i unwelcome to
how the light gets in it's a pleasure to
be able to chat to you tonight
i think the first question i have to ask
you because i have to ask that everyone
during this
strange year is where have you been
during the pandemic and
how's it been for you well rana thank
you very very much for having me
on uh so we have been my husband and my
children i we
have been sheltering in uh the nor
well it's in the west of america
as you know with my safety issues i am
not very keen on
seeing exactly where we were uh but uh
quite uh isolated
and it's the type of uh place where you
would say
even before the pandemic
there was a great deal of distancing but
it was perfect for us
have you found that being i mean as
you've said because of
safety issues and we're going to talk
i'm sure more about that during our
conversation in terms of
your personal safety you perhaps got
used to having to be very wary about
people around you
before the rest of us did for different
reasons but have you found that
essentially being enforced into a kind
of isolation
has been helpful to your work style has
it been problematic has it not changed
things that much for you
i think it did change things and did
change things quite dramatically uh i
so this started happening in 2002 for me
that's a long time ago and uh you know
i was in my early 30s uh was having a
great deal of fun
going out and socializing i used to do a
lot of
outdoors biking and stuff like that and
a lot of it had to stop
so i had to adjust and at the time you
know there were a few individuals who
were going through that
but now with the pandemic and again
with radical islamist threats on the
rise
more and more people are familiar with
that pattern uh it's been a change
but i think the the main thing is for
one to learn to adapt to it
psychologically so it doesn't get you
down
and adapting psychologically is
something that in different ways and
you know for most of us very different
reasons from you have had to do one way
or another so
perhaps there will be kind of some wider
sense of empathy about how much
things have to change you already
mentioned or at least referred to
various things that have happened
in your prominent at times controversial
at times
uh very very kind of action-packed
experience as i think as a politician as
a public intellectual but for those of
us watching for those people
watching tonight here at the festival
who perhaps you know know your name but
don't know that much about your
background
perhaps we could take a few minutes just
to think a little bit about you know
this very
long trajectory that you've made from
birth in somalia to where you are
now in the uh in the united states
and just you know as a quick recap
people who know your stories know a
little bit about this but
your background your upbringing was in
somalia that that was where you started
out
it's where i started out and i was very
young i was about eight or so years old
when my family left
somalia for saudi arabia and we lived
there for a year and then we went to
ethiopia for a year and a half
and then for about 10 or so years in
nairobi kenya
and by then it's what
1992 and my father who had been gone for
10 years
came back and you know long story short
he
arranged uh for me to marry someone of
his choice i didn't agree with that
and i found an opportunity to escape
when i was uh
supposed to go through germany so this
man that he married me off to
was a citizen of canada and instead of
going to canada
from germany i took a train from bonn
to amsterdam and this was on this was
july
24 1992 and and i never looked back
so that's really the kind of turning
point in your in your life and
you spent um some time in the
netherlands
uh becoming very involved in what you
might call
broadly speaking politics but also
particular politics to do
with different communities with the
interactions between them and sometimes
the confrontations between them and
you're a member of parliament for a
while as
well that's some years ago now but
looking back on that you know how do you
think about that period
so i look uh you know i look back i was
in holland for 14 years
and i look back on those 14 years and i
just think they were
fantastic years for me it was you know i
came to a country that prided itself on
freedom and gave me lots of
opportunities
and i took those opportunities i learned
the language i became a translator
interpreter
i went to the university of leyden and
at some point
i went to work for a think tank and at
the think tank they were struggling with
the question of
integration we call it a simulation here
in the u.s
but integrating into society and
a number of my colleagues my senior
colleagues said well how did you do it
you've been here only for 10 years at
that point
um and i threw myself in trying to
answer that question grapple with that
question
and it was a line that led me to think
after i had looked into
some of the north african you know
immigrants from north africa and their
children
from turkey and their children and then
other places iraq somalia syria
afghanistan those places
and i just pointed out you know if you
allow if you emancipate these women
these girls and women you allow them to
finish school
and they can choose their mates and they
if they
get given the same opportunities as
young white dutch girls
then the integration problem in a
generational or so will completely
resolve itself
at the time i didn't realize how
controversial that was
and i still think it's it's a truism but
it's still controversial so
let me dig a little bit into you know
how you came into and then articulated
those views because you've already
mentioned from your earlier life that
you took this
very brave and i should imagine pretty
unusual decision you know
when this potential forced marriage was
being put before you that you know as
you say you pretty much got on train
and and didn't come back so you already
clearly had something going on inside
you that
sent you in that direction even before
you got to the netherlands
and then when you were in the
netherlands clearly what you saw there
hugely influenced your thinking so you
know how much of this was here
there from the start and how much was
developed by your experience
once you've got to to to holland so
i want to say first of all it wasn't
just oh i got on a train and
left and never looked back it was much
more complicated than that
obviously growing up as a young girl i
had been exposed to
um you know my mother and the way her
life seemed to be falling apart she
never had any control over anything
she didn't she couldn't read or write
and that made her
dependent on my father and my father
abandoned us he was gone
for ten years after he had brought my
mother to a country
that to her was strange she didn't speak
the language she couldn't uh
she couldn't rely on her relatives the
way she was lying on her relatives in
somalia that being saudi arabia
well in saudi arabia also she felt she
was quite a stranger there but at least
we had some relatives there
it's a muslim country etc my mother
thought she was happy in saudi arabia
the rest of us were not
but i mean there was this whole process
even my
classmates at school some of them were
forced into marriages or went into
arranged marriages at about
age 15 16 17 i saw these young girls
you know become little old women before
my very eyes
they gained weight they had children
they had become i felt that their lives
were stunted
and so it was clear to me what i didn't
want
i didn't want to be like my mother i
didn't want to be like those classmates
and then so when i was married off to
this man from canada
i thought if there's a way i can get out
of this
i will and once i saw that opportunity
in germany i thought well this is my
chance either do it now
or it's never going to happen it's an
extraordinary story i suppose what i
meant by that was that as you said you
had
classmates uh you had other people
around you who were faced with similar
choices but they didn't
take the same you know very brave step
that you did so
there must be something quite personal
so about you that you felt motivated
this way in a way that
those around you in similar
circumstances i guess did not
well i just also want to say i was
really lucky i was 22 years old when i
was married off some of those girls were
married
at 15 or 16 or 17. so if i had been that
young if i had been a child
just like them i don't think i would
have had the strength
to live i also knew of a number of girls
who actually did leave
a number of women who rebelled against
their families and said i'm not going to
be married off and i'm not going to do
what i'm told
and it ended badly for some of them uh
and i i still i'm in contact with
some of those girls and when i say badly
i mean
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest
ideas